[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello good morning and welcome to Sophie
Ridge on Sunday now it feels like the
Prime Minister has plenty of number one
priorities at the minute but solving the
strike crisis is surely top of the pile
the nurses union says twice as many of
its members will walk out next time
teachers are likely to vote to strike
two and there's still no deal with rail
unions not a great look for a prime
minister who primes himself on
competence but it's a former prime
minister who is the subject of an awful
lot of Westminster chatter after picking
up a million pound donation I guess
Boris Johnson was never the time to sit
quietly on the back benches lots to
discover uh just consider even and
discover with our guests this morning we
will be joined in a moment by the
transport secretary Mark Harper and for
labor we'll be talking to the shadow
Northern Ireland secretary that's Peter
Kyle
we'll speak to Dr Philip Banfield the
chair of the British Medical Association
which is balloting Junior doctors at the
moment over more strikes in the Health
Service and we'll also speak to one of
the city's big beasts John Allen chair
of the UK's largest Supermarket Tesco
and the UK's largest house Builder
developments plus I'm really looking
forward to this we've spoken to the
Ukrainian mp letia vasilenko on the show
before but always from our home country
this time she's going to be joining us
live in the studio
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well absolutely packed show today so
let's start shall we with those strikes
across public services and the railways
just a few moments ago I spoke to the
transport secretary not copper
yesterday two school girls and four
women were shot in a drive-by shooting
in London a girl of seven is fighting
for her life and of course this comes
off the back of shootings in Liverpool
Ellie Edwards 25 year old killed
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Cabell
does Britain have a problem with gun
crime well I can't comment on obviously
on this terrible case yesterday there's
obviously a live investigation underway
but look it's one of the reasons why
we've recruited 15 000 more police
officers since 2019 since the election
when we made that commitment and also
we've seen an effect from that in London
for example which is where this latest
case was we've seen the police seizing
um a significant number of weapons and
we've seen a reduction in violent crime
of seven percent but obviously each
individual tragedy is terrible and my
thoughts go out to those families
concerned and I know the police will be
looking at this case and making progress
as fast as they can is it too in easy
for people to get guns well look we have
incredibly tough laws in this country
about people not being able to get guns
and obviously it depends on them but
then it obviously depends on on
incredibly good policing which is to say
is why we've recruited more police
officers to make up for the short forms
we've recruited more police officers and
that's why we've seen a reduction in in
violent crime and I hope that a positive
trend continues okay now teachers have
backed plans for a strike next month
they say it's likely to follow the
pattern of the Rel Union and you of
course know more than anyone how
disruptive those rail strikes have been
what impact could strikes in schools
have well first of all we don't we don't
know that we've seen some briefing in
some newspapers the only ballot result
that we have seen for for a teacher's
Union actually was that it didn't reach
the threshold and therefore they're not
able to I think that was the nasuwtn not
able to actually go out on strike but
clearly any strikes anything disrupting
children's education will be very
regrettable children obviously have
their education disrupted during the
covid pandemic the last thing we want to
see is children's education disrupted
now that's why the education secretary
for example met and her team met
teachers unions to talk about the
government's evidence the independent
pay review bodies and to listen to the
concerns that teachers have got and
that's what the government wants to do
is back to the independent pay review
bodies and it wants to listen to the
concerns that the teachers have about
you know about education
um I want to talk about the pair of your
body in a moment but you know the
National Education union says that pays
for them by 23 percent relative to
inflation since 2010. it's a complaint
that's echoed in our Health Service as
well we read today that the nursing
Union has said that twice as many nurses
are going to be walking out in February
I mean what impact could that have on
patient care will safe numbers be
maintained well look on the Health
Service again we we've put an extra a
significant amount of money into the
Health Service in the Autumn statement
an extra 14 billion pounds and in fact
not just into Health but also
importantly into social care because
that's one of the things that's causing
some of the delays in in a e on pay
we've supported the independent pay
review body so on the Health Service
this is really important there there
were recommendations that for example
would see the starting salary of a nurse
increase by 1400 pounds and we accepted
those recommendations in full
um and of course what happened this week
again were ministers met the health
unions to listen to their concerns about
pay and other working conditions and
also to talk about the government's
evidence to the pay review bodies for
the forthcoming year I just want to Deep
dive a little bit into the pay review if
I may because look this is what we
always get from the government that it's
all down to the independent pay review
body that you're accepting the
recommendations I just feel like it's a
bit more complicated than that actually
and so in your letter to them last year
you said it's vital that planned
Workforce growth is Affordable and
within the budget set particularly as
there is a direct relationship between
pay and staff numbers and it's the same
with this year's letter so in this
year's letter you say it has to be
within the budget set and then you go on
to say in the current economic context
it's particularly important that you
also have regard to the government's
inflation Target which is two percent
when forming recommendations so you're
effectively saying look guys this is
what we budgeted for pay if you go over
it people are going to get snacked and
you're going to contribute to inflation
doesn't sound that independent well no
we've set out the context which is we've
set out what the Health Service budgets
are and as I said we've put an extra 14
billion pounds into that and there are
significantly more nurses and more
doctors
you could get their recommendations
first before I think it's unfortunately
what the pay review body say would be a
good idea I think it's important to set
out the context they should know what
the overall economic context is that's
part of the government evidence the
other thing they look at they're
specifically tasks to look at
Recruitment and Retention so that's one
of the things for example the unions
have said they're concerned about that
that's another important thing the pay
review board is look at so they look at
Workforce workforce planning and then of
course they also get evidence in from
the trade unions which will be looking
at it from their perspective so the
pay-per-view body has evidence across
the board they have the government's
views the Union's views and then they
come to an independent View and last
year that's what the government accepted
and by the way they've also complained
that you give your evidence so late that
they can't actually really influence it
because your evidence is so late that
the budgets have been set I just want to
have a look at their own response
because the independent pay review
themselves say in settling the
Department of Health and Social care and
the NHS budget which totals 173.8
billion pounds the government assumed a
headline pay Award of two percent for
NHS staff the department has an
additional one percent contingency which
it's choosing to make available
providing an overall affordable headline
pay Award of up to three percent so you
pretty much set the parameters don't you
make an assumption of what they're going
to do and you say look you've got a one
percent contingency here if you don't
then people will get well you have to
make a when you're setting the budget
for the NHS you obviously you have to
make some assumptions
and before you set the budget this is my
point well then you could say this is
what they say should happen on pay let's
form the budget around well if we did
that then what you would do is you'd get
lots of health trusts coming to us
saying we'd set the budgets very late in
the day so look we've set the budgets
for the Health Service
um we've made some assumptions but we'll
look at what the independent pay body
says and I think people should judge us
by what we've done in the past last year
we accepted in full the recommendations
of that independent pay-per-view body
that's what we delivered
um and so and that's what led to pay
rises in the NHS in line with the rest
of the economy but which were focused
actually at the lower paid
um members of Staff which meant they
actually had larger pay Rises which I
think is the right thing to do
um just before we move on to rail
strikes and with more nurses getting on
strike with doctors potentially striking
too
you know you're obviously like a a
politician but you're also human are you
worried about the current situation in
the NHS and could strikes have an impact
on patient safety well look clearly um
when health staff go on uh strike you
know that is obviously going to have an
impact on the Health Service we have to
put detailed contingency plans in place
uh working with the NHS and Health
Service managers to make sure we can
still deliver
Safe Care even on days when there are
strikes but there is clearly an impact
when significant numbers of Staff don't
come to work what is that impact then
well the impact can be seen from the
fact that you know take ambulance
services for example people have to wait
longer for an ambulance to turn up and
that's of course regrettable which is
why Health ministers are sitting down
listening to the trade unions will
accept the pay review body uh we
accepted the pay review body
recommendations last year and we look
forward to ones this year we're very
committed to delivering on those and
that's why we put a huge amount of extra
resources into the Health Service okay
um let's talk rail strikes shall we
there has been some talk of potential
progress uh this week this is how it's
been reported train operating companies
are set to make a new offer to striking
rail workers this week after receiving a
revised mandate from the government
yeah this is going to sound a bit silly
but what does that actually mean a
revised mandate from the government
what's happened well it means the train
operating companies have have got
permission from me to make a new offer
to rail Unions that's what they're going
to be doing
um that's what I was asked to do that's
my role in the process but it's
important now that we give some space
for the employers so that's the train
operating companies and network rail to
continue having discussions with the rmt
to try and reach a conclusion you know
we've had two two of the unions have
settled already with network rail I want
to see hopefully the rmt be able to do
so and to settle with the train
operating companies and there are also
um offers and I hope discussion are
going to be underway with that so the um
train operating companies do need your
permission then to change that or
they've got they've got to revise
mandate to to make an offer to the the
trade unions to cover both pay but all
also importantly reform and as I've said
you before you've got to have pay and
reform and they'll be having those
discussions this coming week on reform
is it true that you've scaled back the
insistence on driver-only operated
trains no we we've been very clear
reform's been on the table all the way
through the whole issue about driver
operating trains I mean they've been in
existence frankly since I was a teenager
which I'm afraid quite a long time ago
in the 1980s
um at 55 percent of passengers travel on
trains where driver only operation is
already in place so this isn't a new
thing no General on General position
you're moving more towards that right is
that insistence been dropped our general
position on reform is that reform is
still incredibly important because it's
it's by having generational reform on
the railways both Network Rail and the
train operating companies so we generate
the savings to pay for the pay Awards to
starve and still have a financially
sustainable Railway we um it is
interesting isn't it because we spend an
awful lot of time talking about trains
whether it's rail strikes uh hs2 but
obviously the majority of Journeys in
the UK taken by bus and also by Road and
do you think that hs2 needs to be
re-looked at it takes an awful lot of
money right well look I think your
general point is is well made and I've
been very clear about that in the
department it's the department for
transport not the department for trains
and I'm very clear that most people for
most of their Journeys travel by Road as
you said either by car or by bus buses
are actually incredibly for important
form of public transport but I think we
we should do all of the things I think
actually hs2 is an important investment
and sometimes people get forget partly
because of the title of it but actually
the most important thing is about the
capacity improvements that it puts so no
change no change so we no no so we the
government's made it clear that
Chancellor made it clear in the in the
awesome statement that the government
remains committed to delivering hs2 it's
about improving the capacity of our rail
network which is important because
otherwise it's going to become congested
in the years to come but that continues
but so does investment in our regular
rail services and also very importantly
in our bus and our road Network
um now just to move on to one of a story
that's been in the uh being covered a
lot today Iran has executed a British
Iranian National after accusing him of
spying for the UK now you've announced
some pretty limited sanctions you've
temporarily withdrawn Britain's
ambassador to Iran for further
consultations
is that it well look the foreign
secretary was very strong in the
language that you used the language
brutal killing of Mr agbari and
obviously our thoughts are with his
family we've recalled the Ambassador for
consultations and I think the foreign
secretary is going to call in the
Iranian charged Affair their most senior
diplomatic official in the UK to make
our views very clear to the Iranian
government and I know the foreign
secretary is going to be thinking about
what more we can do but we've made our
position very clear in the strongest
possible terms about this brutal act and
it just shows up I think the sort of
regime
that the Iranian government is what kind
of regime are they then well they're a
regime that has treated one of their own
citizens a dual national uh in this
incredibly brutal way and that's not
acceptable which is why as I said the
foreign British government's uh views
very very clear indeed both the foreign
secretary and the Prime Minister uh made
very clear that this was a brutal act
and that we're going to take further
steps you are going to take further
steps then we're going to think about
what more we can do and using our
diplomatic influence around the world to
make it very clear to the Iranians that
this sort of terrible behavior is
unacceptable we've we're opposed to the
death penalty in all circumstances and
we condemn this brutal Act
um now Boris Johnson registered a
donation of a million pounds this week
he's still considering a comeback isn't
he
well I don't know what uh Boris
Johnson's thinking about doing you know
he's out making money on the speaking
circuit I'm very clear the prime
minister is focused on the priorities of
the British people in terms of halving
inflation growing the economy cutting
NHS waiting lists and stopping small
boats those are the priorities of the
people that's what the Prime Minister
and the government is focused on that's
what we're spending our time thinking
about rather than thinking about what um
former Prime Ministers are doing come on
though you know people don't donate a
million pounds to MPS who are just going
to be sitting quietly on the back
benches do they well look the former
prime minister is obviously out and
about you know with speaking engagements
but the government and the Prime
Minister are focused on those important
priorities
it's not outside it's a donation from
somebody well look people are free to
donate money to whoever they like and
and as long as those things are properly
registered that's absolutely fine as I
said the Prime Minister and the
government have focused on the Public's
priorities which is what the public
would expect us to be doing is he a
distraction section
no not really I said we're focused on
our priorities which is a halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
NHS waiting lists and stopping small
boats that's what the government's
focused on every day of the week and not
everyone of course thinks that Boris
Johnson is an asset I just want to look
this is one of the pictures of the week
have to say from your predecessor as
transport secretary Grant chaps there's
Boris Johnson there in the middle of the
photo and as if by Magic
hopefully it is coming I promise here we
are he disappears
um
what's going on there well I don't know
you you'd have to ask my uh you'd have
to ask my predecessor what's happened
with his with his social media but look
I think that's one of those little funny
things that happened during the week
that I don't think we need to spend too
much time on but uh very important point
there is our very important focus on our
space program and Britain's ambition to
be a global leader in launching small
satellites I think that's what's
important um talking of Grant sharp some
people say that mclins for example the
rmt said that he's still pulling the
strings to the government over the real
dispute not you no well that's not
correct I mean you'll know since I
became transport secretary I met all the
Trade union leaders uh I was very clear
about making sure we had a new and
improved uh Fair reasonable offer on the
table and both myself and the rail
Minister Hugh Merriman have been
facilitating talks with the rail unions
which is why I think we've made some
progress and I'd hope we can make
further progress I want to stop these
damaging disputes they're bad for people
who work on the railways and they've had
most importantly for passengers and The
Wider economy so I think we made a big
change since I became transport search
and I hope to make continue progress are
you optimistic then
I hope we can get to a solution to these
rail districts
meaningless of course I hope we can I've
made the changes that I think uh are
necessary to get us on a path to that
and I said the trade unions and the
employers are having detailed
discussions and I think it's important
that we give them some space to
hopefully hammer out an agreement that
can be put before union members and it
and be accepted okay thank you very much
indeed pleasure
that was the transport secretary at Mark
Harper now circus Thomas was in Northern
Ireland this week he said that he would
offer support to the prime minister to
get any deal on the protocol through
Parliament that's following rumors of
progress and talks with the EU well we
can speak now to labors Shadow Northern
Ireland secretary Peter Carl thank you
for being with us thanks um before we
get on to Northern Ireland I'm Keen to
get your sort of reaction I guess to the
mark Harper interview he told me I know
that you all I think your chair of the
uh a all part party parliamentary group
on Southern rail so you may have a bit
of a vested interest in rail strikes
um Mark Harper told me that the train
operating companies have got permission
from him to make a new offer to rail
companies and so I guess on the one hand
that's good because it shows potentially
there could be a breakthrough but do you
think that also perhaps supports the
Union's argument that it is the
government that effectively is pulling
the strings here well it always has been
I mean if you look at you mentioned the
southern rail I mean the GTR who runs
Southern rail and thameslink they are
actually because a contract not a
franchise and that's now the system
which is most broadly right across the
country and it means that they can't do
anything without government saying so so
government sets the fairs sets of time
scales uh that the government sets the
stations that each train has to stop at
so the idea that for the entire summer
when all of this unrest was fermenting
between uh staff workers and unions and
the government when Grant chaps refuse
to engage or even meet with unions it
was a real it was a really missed
opportunity he should have been around
the table he should have been engaging
they should the government should have
used the influence it has to try and
broker some of these deals so it's good
that he's starting to now but it isn't
acknowledgment we've had a wasted year
on the strikes have we've had months of
rail strikes and nurses are saying that
more nurses are going to be walking out
next month at teachers bouting for
Action to a public sector workers right
to be taking industrial action they have
the right to take industrial action is
it and it's completely understandable as
to where why they are we have had the
biggest sharpest longest fall in
real-term wages amongst workers across
the public sector so we understand what
the challenges are and that was going
into kovid after kovid placed enormous
stresses and strains on public sector
workers and now we've got the cost of
living crisis as well we can't just look
at this in terms of the relationship
between people workers at their actual
jobs workers back home their rents are
going through the roof the energy price
is going through the roof food costs
going through the roof because our
economy is being fundamentally
mismanaged and then they have these
challenges that work with the pay which
in real terms has been cut over the last
decade so the mismanagement of the
economy is driving this so it's not
surprising that it's spreading from one
public service to another and damaging
our economy from top to bottom I mean I
guess just to put government sort of
come back to that they would say that
above inflation or inflation matching
pay Rises end up stoking inflation I'm
sure you'll have a view on that as well
and but I'm just Keen to find out what
labor would do because look if you look
at the polls you know you are in line to
be the next government nurses for
example looking for payrolls around 10
is that reasonable well the interesting
thing is the the nurses went into these
negotiations asking for inflation plus
five percent and of course we in the
labor party were honest the economy is
in a mess because of the way it's been
managed particularly in the last year
with the mini budget which blew a hole
in it so we were very honest at the
outset and said that that was
unrealistic and labor would not be able
to deliver those sorts of things now the
nurses have already moved that down to I
think 10 is their negotiating stance
these are things that are coming out in
public these are things that should be
resolved by negotiating in private
between employers and the unions now
that's the question because I am I do
think it's really important you know you
you I can understand why you say look
this is all about the mismanagement of
the economy we totally get why public
sector work as a striking look at their
gas bills what would you do what what is
a fair pay rise well first of all look
what we did do during the 12 there were
13 years of the last Labor guy I don't
want to look at what well no well so if
you want to look at what the future we
are that same party we are that same
party with a party that respects the
public finances with a party that gets
the economy growing firing on all
cylinders and we're a party which knows
how to manage public services and deals
with pay and conditions so if we were
negotiating from now we would have open
negotiations between government and the
public sector workers via the unions and
with their unions and we would include
pay and conditions in those negotiations
because clearly that's what the unions
are asking for that's what they need we
know that the unions are moving and
willing to move you can see how the
nurses unions have moved quite
considerably from their starting point
the government has to move as well and
go in and actually be willing to have
negotiations Sophie we're talking about
statecraft here why isn't Northern
Ireland in such a mess because of a
failure of statecraft and neglect from
the government here why is it that think
that when the prime minister it goes to
Scotland he comes back empty-handed in
an acrimony and positions widen they
don't heal because we have a government
that can't do statecraft 101 they can't
get the basics of running any of the
relationships that are essential to
running an economy with its Public
Services the economy more broadly and
its International relationships but also
here domestically across the United
Kingdom itself we need to have a
government that takes statecraft
diligence and graph the basics of
running a government seriously and when
people look at kierstama and I hope his
top teams too they see those qualities
in Spades so I know what you think of
Rishi Cena statecraft I know what you
think about the last Labor government
but I'm still a bit unclear about what
you'd actually do when it comes to
public sector pay well I've said we will
negotiate we will engage in negotiations
on pay and conditions Rachel Reeves as
Chancellor would also get the essentials
the basics right of running economy we
want to reform the economy and get
growth into it we've got the plan to
deliver growth through reforming
business rates which would turbocharge
small businesses and and rejuvenate High
streets right the way through to a green
Prosperity fund which will recapitalize
and convert our economy to get it ready
and equipped for the challenges of Net
Zero all of these things are things that
we would do with the economy to get the
basics right and we would also engage
fulsomely in those negotiations with
employers we've done it before and the
labor next Labor government will do it
again I've been quite interesting
quite a Punchy interview too over the
Sunday Telegraph effectively you know
saying that look the NHS that we talk
about it have been the admiration for
the world but actually you know it's
kind of Reform or die
do you think we need to be a bit more
honest I guess in politics and
Westminster about the state of the NHS
well I think here in his article today
in the telegraph he's been quite starkly
honest it's not the Envy of the world in
fact the world's relationship with the
NHS at the moment is a difficult one
because we are now recruiting we're all
doctors from abroad than we are actually
producing through training back home
that means that you know that the
government have turned our NHS in in our
country into a parasite we're going
around scouring the world looking for
talent to bring back to our NHS because
we're failing to reduce these doctors
and nurses domestically now we have a
plan by canceling the non-dom status to
fund the doubling of training of doctors
nurses and midwives and it will be the
biggest growth in training in the
history of the NHS but we that That's
the basis of the plan to tackle the
workforce challenges we have we also
need to reform the pensions for doctors
we're working with the BMA on that so we
can make sure that people aren't forced
to take early retirement and we can get
people who have retired back into the
service I'm interested um you say that
we're actually a bit of a parasite and
taking you know doctors and nurses from
other countries do you think there's
something almost a bit morally dubious
then with almost like going to countries
many who are poorer than the UK and
taking the doctors that they've trained
it's not the sign of a healthy economy
you know the the the the the the economy
of our NHS that we are so dependent on
taking Talent from the rest of the world
and we're incapable Britain in the 2020s
is incapable of producing enough doctors
for our own needs domestically so what
the labor party will do is double the
training of doctors and nurses this
government cut 3 000 training places
from our universities and our training
facilities in the last year at a time
when we need to double it so this is
again the mismanagement of our NHS and
also a failure to think long-term and
strategically about the future of the
NHS because if you're not training
enough doctors now then in five ten
years time we're not still not going to
tackle the problems that we have today
that's why we need to get a labor
government in there with a plan of fully
costed plan to get the doctors and
nurses and midwives into our NHS that we
need who are trained here in our country
and I want to talk to you with your at
Northern Ireland at hat on now there's
been lots of discussion about the
protocol I mean for years basically
right and you obviously have
conversations with people on different
sides of the debate
is it your sense that we might be edging
closer to a resolution
well we're certainly hearing that
negotiations are going better than
before but we keep on hearing these
briefings we keep on we've had 18 months
of discussions about mood music rather
than content so we really just need to
see what is going to be delivered by
these negotiations rather than just
constant negotiations on the tone it
shows just how poor this whole process
has been that we've had a year and a
half of conversation about the tone of
conversations rather than the content of
the company and you're willing to back
the government effectively on this
you've so the government published it's
uh it's command paper with all of its
negotiating Styles 18 months ago the EU
did so 15 months ago and there's a big
overlap in the middle it's about data
sharing it's about the difference
between whether you have a fast track or
a Green Lane we've spent 18 months
negotiating over something which really
should be dealt with in a matter of
weeks not years it's extraordinary to me
that the previous generation led by Tony
Blair delivered peace in Northern
Ireland this lot can't get a prawn
sandwich across the Irish sea so we
really need to just get around the table
negotiate because Northern Ireland has
suffered from neglect neglect from this
government here and the fact that every
time we have conversations positions
widen we need to bring people together
because Northern Ireland suffers most it
always does when things go wrong in the
in the United Kingdom and all night and
suffers most just finally you're not
only supported a second of friend and
you even move the motion for it and it
has the Commons in 2019 you said it you
felt hurt and groomed betrayed when it
didn't get enough support
has brexit made us poorer
actually the brexit deal at the Bryce
Johnson negotiated has made us poorer
and we need to address that you know
kirstan has been really clear about this
we need to build on that deal you know
for example the only brexit make us poor
do you think I think we could what we
could have done is just fully fully
explored our potential outside of the
single market and that's what the labor
party aspires to do I don't think we've
touched the sides of the country of what
is possible outside of the single Market
you know for example you've got Peter
Carl saying about the opportunities
outside the single Market well Sophie
when when things change in in public
when something fundamental happens in
politics you lose a big vote where we
have a general election and the country
decides to go in a different direction
the political landscape changes and I'm
a politician that respects that so the
political landscape has changed we're in
a new reality and I accept it and I
fully want to explore the potential that
we have as a country right now not as
one that we had 10 years ago I was very
emotionally engaged in in that debate I
fought very very hard I lost the country
chosen New Direction and we need to
fully explore our potential I don't
think we have even touched the sides of
what we've done because the government
is governing by ideology under kirstama
we're being pragmatic we want to rebuild
the relationships that we have around
the country we want to rebuild our
economy out of the rubble of 10 years of
austerity followed by two years of
crises we want to make sure that we can
rebuild our Public Services you know
these are the challenges that we have
and we can only start once we have the
general election and get a prime
minister that actually cares about all
of these things in a non-ideological way
but in a way that actually has
enthusiasm for the future of the country
not the kind of Doom and Gloom and the
governing by rail that we have with the
Tories okay we are at time thanks very
much being on the program thank you for
today thanks be to Carl uh there you're
watching at safely Ridge on Sunday at
lots to chew over whether it's the rail
strikes or the state of the NHS are with
the end of the world or are we a
parasiter as Peter Carl says and still
to come on the program this morning
we've got lots of guests coming up
including the president of the British
Medical Association Dr Philip Banfield
will be joining us and a little later
we'll hear from one of the city's
biggest names the chair of Tesco John
Allen plus we're going to be reflecting
a week of the Westminster accounts the
special new Sky News project to bring
greater transparency to money in
Westminster that we launched on this
program seven days ago
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well these states of the NHS will remain
the biggest concern for many people
there was yet more worrying data at this
week showing just how long people are
waiting for treatment and of course it
means solving the strike crisis is ever
more pressing the Royal College of
nurses says that twice as many nurses
could walk out next time or the British
Medical Association is batting Junior
doctors now over a future strike it's
chair Dr Philip Banfield is with us now
thanks so much for being with us good
morning Sophie um first of all can you
just give us a bit of an honest
appraisal about what it's actually like
to work at the NHS right now well our
members have have never seen so much uh
stress so much moral injury from not
being able to undertake the care that
they're so desperate to give this has
arisen because we just don't have enough
beds for the Health Service need at this
point in time now part of that is not
being able to charge people from
hospital and that creates a a kind of
Log Jam but this is years and years of
running down the number of beds so we've
got half the number of beds available to
the Health Service that we did 30 years
ago we talked about years and years I
think that is quite important isn't it
because
um the government often talks a lot
about covert and says that this is a
part of the knock-on effect of the
pandemic is that right uh what the
pandemic has done is is aggravate a
situation that was deteriorating and we
have been highlighting really for 10
years or more so you know if you look at
the figures the waiting list had gone
from 2.6 to 4.4 million before the
pandemic
um you know it's gone over 7 million now
this is an absolute National Scandal and
we we spoke on the program last week to
at the chair of the sort of acute
emergency medicine and he was talking
about in fact this basically means
people dying and if an ambulance can't
get to them in time if they're waiting
for a e you know is that is that the
route around it uh that's a really good
word he's brutal on the front line at
the moment we see our GP colleagues you
know buckling under the weight not only
of of people who are worried about
things that are going on now but they're
bearing the the brunt of the backlog
because you know people keep going to
their their GP and what does that mean
does that mean like you know hundreds of
people trying to call eight in the
morning to try and get an appointment
and failing to well it does it means
that they're filling the face-to-face
slots and having 30 40 50 online
consultations as well to try and fit in
but what it translates to is you know
patients making conscious decisions with
their GPS not to go to hospital when
they when they need to because they
don't want to languish on a a hospital
uh trolley and my wife who is a is a GP
had 12 hours on a on an a e trolley with
uh chest pain thinking that she was
going to to die on her own because I
wasn't around at the time and you know
this is the kind of trauma that is being
suffered by patients and the staff could
not be trying harder you know now
there's no fault on the staff how on
Earth emergency department staff keep
going and we do know that it's affecting
their mental health and we do know that
it's causing burnout I'm really sorry to
hear about your wife that's incredibly
sort of stressful situation for her and
also for you she's better now that's
getting work so I'm glad but it does I
guess highlight what so many people are
experiencing and we've seen nurses and
ambulance workers going on strike at
Doctor strikes inevitable uh they're not
inevitable at all we're balloting at the
moment and the result will come in five
weeks time and now is the time for us to
get down with government and vice versa
to find a resolution to this now we met
with the Secretary of State for the
first time
but actually now that we've done that it
was not as negative as I was expecting
um there are things that the Secretary
of State can do business with us over
and and that would include uh trying to
uh give back confidence in the pay
review bodies for example but there are
things as he points out that it's the
Prime Minister and Chancellor uh who are
controlling
um and uh he made the same offer to us
as he's made to the other unions which
is try and help him with the economic
argument and the economic argument is
strong we're spending a lot of money on
locums with the the fact that they're
the health and wealth of the population
is deteriorating and that gap between
the poor and the rich is widening and
that translates into you know an
economic crisis as well and you know it
doesn't make sense uh to make people
sicker and we know that the country is
getting sicker as a whole uh let's get
people back into work then they can pay
their taxes so uh you know I for me it's
a very straightforward uh Market uh
economics argument uh doctors are
leaving the NHS they've got choice these
are bright young graduates
um you know their entry pay just over 14
pounds an hour you know full pay
restoration for them means 18 pounds an
hour you know we have to decide as a
country what the value for the expertise
for junior doctors is and Junior doctor
others are not Junior by any means these
are skilled highly trained professionals
and
I'm interested quite heartened I guess
to say that you think that it perhaps
wasn't quite as negative as you would
expect when you met with a health
secretary
um Steve Barkley and do you think that
he's willing to move on pay if you give
back a bit on reform there was that
effectively what happened well I've met
him for just over an hour right that's
the first time that that I've met
um so you know it is all for what
happens next
um and the indications are that we will
be having that dialogue while we're
having dialogue there's always the
possibility of averting industrial
action no doctor wants to go on strike
no nurse wants to go on strike we feel
that we're being backed into it
um I'm interested to get your thoughts
on Labor's position as well uh kissed
armor in an interview today with the
Sunday Telegraph so the NHS must reform
will die and the idea that the service
is still the Envy of the world is wrong
is he right
well when the NHS works it is superb is
it worth right now you cannot beat it
and they're a pocket there are times
when it works it's not working for
everyone
right so there are some really really
brilliant bits of the NHS that happen
day in and day out and we are
emphasizing that the NHS is the future
for this country because it should be
the most effective and efficient Health
Service you can have because if you
don't take profit out of it that money
should be available
but I mean labor says that they would
like to for example uh bypass GPS allow
people to have safe self-refer is that
is that a good idea I met with web
streeting this uh week and we had to
agree to disagree that he doesn't
understand general practice
um and you know the GPS are one of the
most efficient and effective parts of
the Health Service in the way that they
manage risk they are superb at it so you
don't think that labor really
understands how the GP system works well
I think that they have a lot of work to
do between now and an election we have
offered to help them with that we'll do
business with anyone who has the right
policies this is not about Party
politics for us as a BMF so why is
self-refer a bad idea because some
people think look it's obvious you know
I can't get through to my GP and I can
just self-refer way more efficient
um it's not efficient from the point of
view that uh what tends to happen is you
have people who are the worried well and
the people who really have an issue say
I don't want to bother my doctor right I
don't want to have
um uh take up someone else's time so you
then end up
paradoxically with a widening Health
inequality because some people will just
refer themselves straight to
um Specialists when actually they don't
need to be correct okay understood
um I mean I guess what West rooting
would say is that you may be part of the
problem he's described the BMA as
hostile to his plans he says he's not
afraid to take on the doctors and
Kirsten as well telling me last weekend
we've got to have battles my experience
of Reform is there will always be people
who say I wouldn't do that I disregard
that we're not going to back down the
first time someone says I wouldn't back
down or I wouldn't do this
they're willing to go into battle with
you doctors are not the problem they are
the solution
you need the us as experts to deal with
the problems of the NHS we are not
averse to change it's a complete fallacy
that doctors want in a Health Service to
stay as it is we're the first people to
say we want change in the Health Service
but please can we have it evidence-based
please can you listen to Frontline staff
and please can you invest properly in a
Health Service we can be proud of uh
really interesting to talk thanks so
much to be uh on the for being on the
program thank you so much thank you
uh well uh lots that we've discussed uh
today uh not least of course the state
of the NHS and what should be done when
it comes to reform uh on this program
last week we brought you the first of a
series of exclusive special reports said
that we're part of a long-running Sky
News and tortoise media investigation
bringing greater transparency to the
money in politics so it's called the
Westminster accounts
over 17 million pounds that the total
amount of outside earnings the MPS have
declared in the course of this
Parliament the more transparency the
better I think transparency is really
important do you think that it is
helpful to pull all this stuff together
yes in one database yes for the first
time we can sort MPS in order of what
they make from second jobs and other
outside earnings this here is the
leaderboard the highest earning MP in
this Parliament former prime minister
Theresa May she's earned over two and a
half million pounds from speeches like
this one in Saudi Arabia Shadow foreign
secretary David Lammy has been a busy
man he lists more sources of outside
income than any other MP Lloyds of
London JPMorgan Chase Canary Wharf group
GSK some of those are quite shocking
third biggest donor to MPS in this
Parliament and PM connect they give well
over a quarter of a million pounds to
just three well-known labor MPS we're
trying to get in touch with people from
npm connect do you know whether I can
speak to them or how I can contact them
the mystery of IX Wireless a small
Northern Broadband company which is
donated to 24 conservative MPS totaling
more than a hundred and thirty thousand
pounds I'm actually standing outside
Rebel house and there doesn't seem to be
anybody here weeks ago we asked Shadow
Home Secretary Yvette Cooper Shadow
Health secretary Wes treating and Dan
Jarvis basic questions about the firm
that had donated them hundreds of
thousands of pounds only today after the
Westminster accounts aired and we had
raised those questions in public did we
get a response apbgs are used through
the secretariats and thought that you
run in order to push particular
corporate agendas
is that true
I think it might be true we need to have
a an understanding of of what their
agenda is these are the labor leaders
top datas note the top spots aren't
unions but wealthy businessmen one of
his party's biggest donors is also a key
just stop oil backer people like
Extinction Rebellion I gave them some
money uh help them get started just our
boil same thing it's a million pounds
um to to the office of Boris Johnson
limited and it's from a big Tory and
pro-brexit donor let's reflect upon
numbers and in particular those numbers
that were shown away on by Sam Cooke's
of sky
or should we reflect a bit on the impact
of the Westminster accounts now in the
reaction over the last week I'm very uh
excited to say athletical correspondent
Liz Bates is on the show for us today
great to have you here on Sunday morning
Liz it's good to be here so what has the
reaction been then over the last week
well you saw something with some of it
there I think there's been
um a mixed reaction so you saw in the
chamber at premises questions at the SMP
really jumped on it and they were sort
of calling for more transparency we've
heard this many times
um before but they want to see a
complete overhaul there were other MPS I
think many of them publicly welcomed it
but I think privately there's always a
feeling among MPS that
um more transparency and the public
being able to see some of these figures
more clearly
um might make them feel that there's a
level of corruption in politics that
maybe isn't right it sort of brings back
memories of the expenses Scandal so I
think there's always there's also been a
bit of that as well but I think what's
clear when you actually look through the
tools and they're they're on our site
you can see many programs that we've
made about them and they're very easy to
access and use this an improved level of
transparency will in the end I think
build back trust in politics because one
of the problems and this is what this
project was trying to address is that
the information is out there a lot of it
is published but when you go to look for
it it still feels like it's all over the
place sometimes it's opaque and
sometimes when you do find it still
feels difficult to understand so I think
that this project has done a really good
job of bringing it all together
simplifying it and and creating now a
tool that can that can give us the
ability to ask further questions yeah
and you just have to look at some of the
stories that have come out
um by people being able to access the
information such a easy and readily
available way and thanks for the
analysis Liz we're going to be having
lots more from Liz later on because
she's gonna be back with us at half past
nine when we're going to take a look
back analyze our interviews on the
program this morning so you have half an
hour of Liz then which is all good and
speak to you later at Liz thank you
now the economy inflation over 10 don't
need to tell you that energy and food
prices rising even faster the biggest
squeeze on living standards in living
memory and the UK potentially on the
brink of recession well it's safe to say
the economic picture is grim at best and
a difficult reality for many people
across the country well we're joined Now
by one of the city's big names he is a
chair of the UK's biggest Supermarket
Tesco and the country's biggest house
Builder Barrett developments John Allen
so really no one better to speak to
delighted to have you on the program
delighted to be here now you're the
child Tesco had pretty good Christmas by
all accounts um but how hard are things
for customers at the minute well I think
it depends on the customer you know
there isn't a one-size-fits-all answer I
think customers are very Savvy they're
working very hard to find ways of
alleviating the impact of rising food
prices so they can trade down they can
use different ingredients they can cook
more at home as opposed to going out but
underneath that of course there are a
large number of people who really are
struggling to make ends meet and we're
very conscious of our responsibilities
not just to those who shop with us but
also those who can't afford to shop with
us which is why we support a lot of food
banks Charities associated with that
Etc are you seeing a change then in
people's shopping habits I was
interested when you were talking about
people shopping more savly uh you know
value items being bought more of what's
going on yeah I think there's a whole
series of mini Trends but they include
people you know cooking more at home as
opposed to going out trading down from
Brands to own label we've been
advertising showing people meals simple
meals they can construct for a with
named ingredients and prices which are
on a per capita basis very low we've
been running ads telling people to check
what you've already got before you go
out and shop because you may be buying
things you don't need and that
contributes to food waste which you know
is massive still in homes but of course
there are people who haven't got fridges
stuff full of food you know and and they
need they need help it's really
interesting to hear you say that and
what is happening with food inflation as
well because it's interesting with
inflation you have the headline rate but
then obviously you have what's going on
under the bottom if you like food
inflation but also particularly you know
some of those Staples as well yeah I
think look it we're not in the business
of making forecasts about food inflation
I did about a a year ago a bit over a
year ago and and more by good luck and
good judgment got happened to get it
right and I made a vow then that I would
have to get it right we want to hear
more of it no no but I but that was a
fluke frankly
um I I'm my chief executive when he
announced our results last week said
that our Hope was that
um the peak of food inflation would
probably arrive around about the middle
of this year but frankly that's an
aspiration as much as a forecast and
um and that doesn't mean prices will
start falling it means they hopefully
will stop stop going up nearly as fast
so we haven't we're away off the peak
I think we've got somewhere to go to get
to the peak and then prices will still
probably continue to rise more modestly
but who knows you know and it's it's a
function of all sorts of things that are
beyond our control Energy prices what
happens in the Ukraine Ukraine harvests
and so on
um so we will see but you know we and
I'm sure other uh supermarkets will can
use strenuously to help our customers
cope you know with the fact that prices
are still going up for example we've
locked a thousand prices until Easter so
that's a thousand prices that people
know are going to be the same at least
until Easter it's a Russian scene
exercise he wants to halve inflation
this year I think that's achievable
I'm I'm not qualified to make that uh
the Judgment I mean it'd be wonderful if
it happened I think inflation will go
down but remember having inflation still
means price is rising at maybe five or
six percent which I think would seem
terrific in comparison with now but
prices would still be going up and if
you're on the breadline that's still
getting harder for you indeed so I think
the uh I I think inflation will start to
come down uh but just how much and when
I think I'm not brave enough to forecast
that makes sense
um just the final sort of forecast
question if you like and it was just a
soft one don't worry
um the economic growth stickers for
November which were released this week
we're actually
surprising like better than some people
expected do you think that we should
have a Slither of optimism I guess that
the landing may be softer than we think
well I think a sliver but you know
individual months figures can be first
of all they get adjusted subsequently
they don't always end up the same as
they start the World Cup may have helped
people were you know buying large
amounts of well I was staying in and
buying large amounts of beer or whatever
to to celebrate so I wouldn't read too
much into uh these figures but one's
hope would be that if we do have a
recession that it's a relatively mild
one and not too prolonged but you know
that's a hope rather than the forecast
we um have talked a lot about inflation
and what it means in people's budgeting
obviously the big worry is that people's
pay isn't keeping up with inflation
what's Tesco's policy been when it comes
to pay well I think we had our normal
pay settlement in the you know first
second quarter of 2022 we then realized
that with racing Rising inflation that
wasn't adequate so we had a second round
negotiations with our unions and our
colleagues and we ended up I think with
a overall rise for our colleagues on the
shop floor of around eight percent last
year and we've told them that we will
start this year's negotiations earlier
in fact in the next couple of weeks so
that if it is necessary to make a
further adjustment and I don't want to
anticipate that we'll be in a position
to do so so I think we think it's
important to keep up with events and you
know you mentioned my relationship with
Barrett barretts have done something
similar you know we've added extra
one-off payments to our people to
because you know if you are at the lower
end paid end of the spectrum this is a
cost of living crisis is a really tough
thing for people to get through it's
much easier for highly higher paid
people which is why both businesses I've
been involved with
the price the salary Rises for
management have been low single digits
because the viewers they can afford to
they've got enough in the pot to be able
to cope with a rise that is below
inflation for a time I have to say the
contrast between Tesco and Barrett
revising and many settlements and what's
happening with the government uh
sticking with the pay review bodies
settlements it's quite Stark
well yes I think I don't know if you
asked me to express an opinion on that
Sophie but I was giving the opportunity
well look let me start by saying I think
I mean Tesco is relentlessly politically
neutral we we want to work with whatever
the government of the day is but you can
have personal views if I express a
personal view rather than the Tesco view
I think you know I think it would be
good and perhaps there are the first
signs of this happening or for
government to start engaging with those
groups of Public Service workers who are
currently unhappy because I think the
only way to settle this will be through
negotiation
understood there's also anecdotal
evidence
um of people leaving jobs in the public
sector like care work or nursing and
coming to work in supermarkets where
they may feel that their pay is
competitive and that the working
conditions are frankly better are you
seeing that I think a little bit I
haven't got any numbers but I know that
you know certainly people are leaving
the care system I think
um and heading towards other uh jobs
including supermarkets including Tesco
I'm not sure about nurses
um but uh you know I think it's a it is
a competitive labor market and and
that's something I think that was
involved in these discussions need to
remain aware of I'm Keen to talk to you
uh with your uh Barrett hat on as well
because there's been lots of concern
about the state of the housing market
um what's your assessment of where we
are well there's definitely a downturn
in demand at the moment I think the rise
in interest rates in the Early Autumn
spiked rises in mortgages and that's
actually put people off by houses
understandably this happens from time to
time in the the house building Market
the house builders I think are perfectly
capable of weathering this storm we all
tend to run with strong balance sheets
knowing that every decade or so there
will be a year or two that are where
there's a downturn I think we'd like to
see more government support particularly
for new uh you know new home buyers
first-time home buyers
and we would like to see some reform of
the planning system to make it easier to
build because the other thing it's
inhibiting the house building sector at
the moment is a planning system which
means you can't actually saw concept of
MPS blocking plan reforms well precisely
um but you know but I think the you know
the house builders are fit and strong
and will survive
um I'm concerned more about people who a
lot of people this year will face as the
end of fixed term mortgages come they
will face much higher mortgage payments
which will add another twist to the cost
of living crisis is for for many
families do you think we're really Brave
we're really aware of just how difficult
that country is likely to be
um
I don't know I think it depends who
you're talking to I'm certainly aware of
it and I think it's uh it's going to
it's going to make life difficult for
many hundreds of thousands of families
uh each year as you know deals uh are
come to an end in a revised and go up
significantly you know the fact that
interest rates have abated a bit is
helpful yes so it's not as bad as it
looked in you know the Early Autumn and
do you think we'd like to see a fall in
house prices this year then yes yeah
okay to make a forecast and I don't like
to make them but absolutely not but I
think it would be very un you know it's
very unlikely there will not be some so
indeed there is some softening already
uh and I think if people go looking for
our houses or any of our competitors
they're all behaving very similarly
they'll find the sort of little
incentives to try to persuade them which
weren't there a year or two ago and I
think that's just understandable
Behavior okay it's been really
interesting to talk thank you so much
for coming in this Sunday morning thank
you
uh to Ukraine now and the Prime Minister
has told president zelenski that the UK
will send some Challenger 2 battle tanks
to Ukraine there are also hopes that
other Western countries will follow suit
this week now Russia this week sees the
salt mining town of saldadar amid bitter
fighting in the area yesterday 14 people
killed by Russian strikes on civilians
and infrastructure at Targets it's the
kind of thing we talk about all the time
uh sadly now the Ukrainian MP lessia
vaselenko has been on the program before
but always from her home country today
I'm very pleased to say that she joins
us live here it's lovely to see you in
person and thank you so much for coming
in a real pleasure to have you uh here
um can you just update us on what's the
latest on the ground in Ukraine it's
been a very difficult weekend and
yesterday the whole country and everyone
whose Ukrainian has been absolutely
devastated at missiles in fact I was on
a call was was a friend early in the
morning yesterday and all of a sudden he
says to me there's explosions but there
has not been any air raid sirens and it
has been the case for most of Ukraine
yesterday there's not been Air Raid
Sirens to warn the people of these
missiles that Russia launched because as
our ministry of Defense reported later
it's the kind of missiles that cannot
really be detected especially from the
direction that Russia was launching
yesterday today and there's as a result
the world has seen the destroyed
residential blocks in abroad the massive
holes from the missiles in in some
Ukrainian Villages just a couple of
kilometers out from Kiev and it's just
been yet another human tragedy added to
the long list of human tragedies caused
by Russia you know I'll say an intro
introduction to you you know there's
been more strikes on civilian targets
civilian targets I mean like you say
that means holes in apartment blocks
right absolutely that means that means
innocent men women children who were not
expecting this on a Saturday especially
after a certain kind of festive period
which was prolonged in Ukraine
and
it's just not something that you expect
it's just not something that and even in
the middle of the war and you know that
your country is in the war every single
moment of the day but still you're sort
of hoping that it will stick to the
Battleground you are hoping that maybe
okay military targets will be targeted
but not your home not the home of your
loved ones of your friends you don't
expect to spend your Saturday on the
phone constantly calling family from
asking whether whether they're alive or
not
and now Ukraine is poised to see more
Russian forces
are you worried about the direction of
the war well we are worried first of all
that there will be more missile strikes
in the coming days because we know from
intelligence that Russia has not
exhausted even half of their Arsenal
that was intended for these attacks and
we know that there is uh missile
launcher
cargo ships in the in the marine regions
ready to go so this is this is something
we are preparing in the short term in
the long term of course and the midterm
uh it is expected that Russia will
regroup and will start relaunching the
attacks especially with spring when the
calls will be uh not so when it will not
be so difficult because of the call to
to make advancements and this is why
Ukraine is constantly on the ask for
more weapons and for these tanks as you
just mentioned that the UK will be
sending tanks Challenger tanks to
Ukraine we are extremely grateful for
that and we are hoping that Germany will
see this as an example to follow and
will eventually give way and give us the
the tanks and the armored vehicles we
have been so desperately asking for to
have that uh that benefit on the
Battleground let's talk about the tanks
and because as you say the UK sending
Challenger 2 tanks the first time a
western country has pledged tanks how
important is that uh the fighting on the
on the ground on the eastern
Southeastern Northeastern Borders or
contact line for Ukraine it's crucial
that we have artillery on the ground
it's crucial that we have tanks on the
ground because this is what Russia is
fighting us with so we need this as
defense vehicles but we also need these
as counter-offensive instruments to push
the Russians back and it is crucial that
we do this by the end of spring that we
get a pushback of Russian forces beyond
the Ukraine Russian board as the 1991
Ukraine Russian borders and and that we
secure the area with with proper defense
structures and facilities and to do that
we need these these heavy weapons which
are the tanks you you said that you hope
Germany follows the UK's example do you
think that some countries
are not doing enough
uh well Germany being one of them I mean
they have these weapons sitting there
that they are not using and that
hopefully fingers crossed they will not
have to use because Ukraine will be
Victorious and will manage to fight off
the biggest aggressor in Europe so for
Germany not to have to use these tanks
they need to be in Ukraine on the ground
fighting and the same goes for every
single country who still has weapons and
the storage units and the storage houses
and is stalling from giving them to
Ukraine because the only threat in
Europe at this moment and one of the
largest threats to Security in the world
is Russia and the only country that can
physically stop Russia is Ukraine and we
are happy to do this on the ground
within our territory we are happy to
push back Russia within its borders but
we need the means to do it and this is
this is why the appeals from our
Minister of Defense from a foreign
minister from our president from every
single Ukrainian gave us weapons give us
the tanks give us the anti-air
weapons and systems that we need give us
the ammunition to go with are you it's
interesting isn't it because um you know
speaking to you today making these calls
is it often that women of Ukraine who
are having to come on programs like this
who are having to speak to the
politicians to travel the world because
the men are fighting it's definitely
easier for the women to cross the
borders even if we're talking about
women who are in politics who are in
people who are in politics or in
government positions it still is easier
because uh the women are not well not
eligible for a mandatory military
service so we are free to cross the
border when when we we like when it
comes to the men if you are from 18 to
60 uh the rule of thumb is that you are
eligible for military service and you
cannot leave the country as you please
you need to get authorizations you need
to prove that you will be coming back
that and that the mission you're going
to abroad is really really necessary
sorry so of course it's easier for the
women to make these appeals but
regardless who's making these appeals
even if it's not ukrainians who are
making these appeals I really wish that
these appeals would be answered because
today the best humanitarian Aid that can
be sent to Ukraine is weapons to fight
off the Russians
um I was really struck by photograph
that you posted on Twitter just before
Christmas
um I think we can hopefully have a look
at it it's of you and your family
can you just explain what's happening in
this picture
well uh this is my youngest uh she's a
toddler 18 month old and we are in a
um makeshift bomb shelter from a
basement in uh in an apartment block
just next door two hours and the thing
is I was uh going out to the park with
Sophia uh because to give her her nap
but she she only naps outside and all of
a sudden uh the there were explosions
which started just the stuff started
blowing up somewhere very close to us
because these explosions were very much
intense and there was the smell of smoke
of sulfur immediately in the air and as
we started making our way back home we
were ushered in by uh just people from
the next apartment block saying come in
come and you need to go into the
basement right now and this is exactly
what happened so her nap was was
interrupted
um of course she's not sleeping there
and there you have my friend in the
picture who said trying to entertain her
with some Peppa Pig
kind of blows my mind you know you talk
about something that is so familiar and
ordinary to so many people watching you
totally won't sleep so you take them in
the prams to try and tell them outside
you know you want them to be quiet so
you put Peppa Pig on the phone
and yet it's in such an extraordinary
situation for a parent I I can't imagine
you know I talked to you as a politician
but also as a mother
um I just can't really grasp
what people in Ukraine are having to go
through uh you know neither can I
because it's just
um it just doesn't sit well with the
ordinary with the normal life of a
person living in the modern world
uh you cannot piece the puzzle together
and I think that after the victory after
Ukraine wins we will have a lot of
mending to do and a lot of healing to do
because all of these things which our
brain doesn't allow us really to
register and to grasp and what we are
actually doing uh they are going to
flood us and there's going to be a lot
of issues to deal with base for the
people who will be coming back from the
front lines as well as the people who
will be coming back from abroad as well
as the people who have had to stay and
live through these Air Raids because it
does feel like the whole of Ukraine it's
a front line the whole of Ukraine is a
Frontline and it's a fact and do you
think that you can win them absolutely
we have no other choice you have no
other choice we have to win this war for
uh democracy sake uh this is an
existential War for Ukraine it's
existential because we want to exist we
want to live so this is why we are
fighting but for uh people who are
supporting us for the UK for example
it's an existential War because it's
existential between good and evil who do
you want to and you won't get to win you
want the world to be a safe place you
don't want to be seeing pictures like
this on Sunday morning and you most
certainly don't want to be living
through pictures like this any day of
your life and in order for this not to
happen you need to make sure that Russia
loses Russia losing must become a very
clear statement in everyone's mind a
very clear idea and one that everyone
can back and support and thank you so
much for being on the program it's been
a real privilege to meet you thank you
thank you Sophie
oh well uh there we go a very a powerful
account there about the reality of so
many families at living in Ukraine
uh just before we go a quick reminder of
our weekly uh podcast if you scan the QR
code on your screen right now you can
find the Sophie Ridge on Sunday a
podcast you can subscribe so that it's
in your feed every week or you can also
find out wherever you get your podcast
as well there's highlights on the
interviews some post-match analysis a
bit of an insight into how we put the
program together and this week we'll be
joined as usual by our editor Scott
Beasley and also our political
correspondent Liz Bates will be giving
us her take as well so yeah just find
that wherever you get your podcast
safety Ridge on Sunday
well that's it for this week's program
in a moment after the break we are going
to be running through today's interviews
seeing what we learned we'll be joined
uh by Liz who's just walking to the
studio right now hi Liz uh thanks for
joining us at this Sunday morning
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look back at some of the interviews that
we've had a bit of an analysis as well
and I'm delighted to say that we have
Liz Bates that political correspondent
uh with us to talk us through all of the
interesting political things it felt
like if you can sum up one thing that
the program was dominated by its strikes
whether it's the railways whether it's
in the NHS potentially teachers as well
do you think we're getting anywhere when
it comes to strikes
I mean first of all I do think that uh
it's absolutely dominating the political
landscape no doubt about it and that's
because it's having such an impact on
people personally we had it with uh the
transport Network for such a long time
and now it's moved into the NHS and
people really feel that very acutely and
that is why politicians for them it is
top of their agenda it absolutely needs
to be sorted out I think one of the
interesting dynamics that is going on is
in in public there's real brinksmanship
I think on both sides from the
government they're putting forward
anti-strike legislation they've been
very critical particularly of ambulance
workers who've gone on strike and
they've talked about uh people in the
rail network going on strike putting the
entire industry at risk in the future of
the industry we've seen exactly the same
type of language from some of the union
bosses but behind the scenes
negotiations continue they keep coming
to the table and for a while there was a
bit of stalemate it does now seem that
there are certainly the government is
Shifting when it comes to some of the
reforms that have been discussed and
even on pay as well and so I think that
aspect of it is quite positive but I do
want to say as well this is the first
time and I think you teased it out
really well with Mark Harper today that
issue of whether the pay review bodies
are independent it's so important
because it's something that the
government says over and over again
they've really used it as a shield in
this standoff I think there is a
question over whether the release in
Independence in that process and I think
that was laid out quite well today yeah
it's interesting isn't it um firstly I
actually agree on the potential uh
progress um it feels like Mark harmful
was kind of oh I can't say anything but
and then even Dr Banfield saying oh yeah
actually my my meeting with the house I
gosh I wasn't as terrible as I thought
it was going to be and so maybe I think
you might be on something there with the
pay review body
um it's interesting because the
government continually comes back to it
doesn't it saying that look these are
the recommendations to the pay with your
body and actually this week um our
producer Jared did a really forensic
look into the exchanges that's been
going on and so we were able to use some
of it in the interview let's have a
little listen to what Liz was referring
to there
the pay-per-view body has evidence
across the board that the government's
views the Union's views and then they
come to an independent view independent
pay review themselves say in settling
the Department of Health and Social care
and the NHS budget which totals 173.8
billion pounds the government assumed a
headline pay Award of two percent for
NHS staff the department has an
additional 1 contingency which is
choosing to make available providing an
overall affordable headline pay Award of
up to three percent so you pretty much
set the parameters don't you you make an
assumption of what they're going to do
and you say look you've got a one
percent contingency here if you don't
then people will get well you have to
make a when you're setting the budget
for the NHS you obviously have to make
some assumptions and if you could ask
and before you set the budget this is my
point well then you could say this is
what they say should happen on pay let's
form the budget around well if we did
that then what you would do is you'd get
lots of health trusts coming to us
saying we'd set the budgets very late in
the day
yeah it's difficult isn't it because it
does really feel as if the the written
exchanges they're having with the pay
review body they're saying look these
are the parameters and watch inflation
and do be careful because if you do go
over the budget then that's going to
have an impact on Workforce members yeah
absolutely and I think what's quite
clear and and you brought it out very
well there is that you can come again
but the the hands of the pay review
bodies are really tied by the government
I think there was another moment where
Mark Harper was talking about the rail
strikes and he said I have given
permission uh for the employers to go
forward and make a different offer so I
think this line that the government has
taken Within These strikes that they are
just simply a broker they're bringing
people to the table is quite clearly not
the case and it is ministers that really
need to move on this issue if there's
going to be progress
as I said though I think there is
movement behind the scenes fingers
crossed we'll have to see whether or not
that does um come to the fall yeah I
think it was interesting when he talked
about that rail thing as well and
potentially uh feeding the arguments
some of the unions have had that
actually they've needed the government
to give something before they can move
um let's just have a little listen to
the NHS interview as well uh shall we
because we also uh spoke to the chair of
the British Medical Association who
speaks for doctors in the UK that's Dr
Philip Barnfield he mentioned actually
about his own wife's experience on the
NHS and illustrate the points that he
was making
my wife who is a is a GP had 12 hours on
a on an a e trolley with uh chest pain
uh thinking that she was going to to die
on her own because I wasn't around at
the time and you know this is the kind
of trauma that is being suffered by
patients and the staff could not be
trying harder
laughs I have to say you know whenever
you talk to people in the NHS
they just feel like they're on the edge
um and it does feel like that's changed
and I spent a long time talking to
people in NHS throughout covert as well
but it does just feel like the kind of
alarm right now is really quite
something it does and that story I mean
it's a terrible story to hear it's a
terrible experience we're starting to
hear that on a regular basis and many
people will have had similar experiences
within the NHS recently I think what the
government has been trying to say is
that these pressures are largely caused
by covid and of course Kobe calls extra
pressures uh on the NHS we all lived
through it we know what happened during
that period
um clearly the government want to try to
bring the numbers back into some kind of
control but I do think that years before
that things were going in the wrong
direction for so many different reasons
but we we know first of all that many of
the staff including nurses boards so
doctors are overworked exhausted they
feel underpaid many of them are leaving
the profession but there's other much
more long-term issues like sorting out
the relationship between the NHS and
social care we've been promised that by
successive governments it's never really
materialized and that has an impact on
beds right because if the issue is beds
and they can't discharge people properly
into care homes or under social care in
the community then that's taking more
space absolutely and I think
um it's issues like that that covid has
laid it all bare if you like suddenly an
extra pressure has come onto the NHS and
what we find out is that over many years
the resilience of the NHS has been
eroded and that's the position that
we're in now and that's why the
government I think both the government I
mean the labor party are talking about
this as well needing a much longer term
plan for the NHS it's about money but
it's also about reform bringing in new
staff and retaining them as well I have
to say Dr Panther was a bit scathing
about Labor's plans though he was saying
that West rooting didn't understand the
NHS
I think Labor's position is quite
interesting because they are working
very hard on on plans for the NHS
they're in a really different position
at the moment as a political party they
are and I speak to a lot of Labor MPS on
a regular basis for a long time I think
they felt really resigned to opposition
and so they were just throwing uh
criticism from the sidelines and never
really thinking about what they would do
in government now they are really
starting to believe that they will form
the next government so they're putting
plans in place I think we're streating
in particular but the party generally
have taken an approach when it comes to
the NHS they want to reform it long term
and they want to in their words make it
about patience rather than about doctors
and so I think they've been butting
heads with the BMA and I think we'll see
more of that in the future and I guess
maybe that's what they say you know
you've got to you know annoy some people
if you're going to push reform through a
battle that they're willing to have
really interesting we also that's one
other thing I do want to talk to you
about at Liz which is uh Boris Johnson
because we did talk to Mark Harper about
Boris Johnson now he's never far away
from the chatter in the tea rooms of
Westminster but particularly at the
minute because he has been given a 1
million pound donation uh I asked Mark
Harper a little bit about that let's
have a listen to what he said
well I don't know what uh Boris
Johnson's thinking about doing you know
he's out making money on the speaking
circuit I'm very clear the prime
minister is focused on the priorities of
the British people in terms of halving
inflation growing the economy cutting
NHS waiting lists and stopping small
boats those are the priorities of the
people that's what the Prime Minister
and the government is focused on that's
what we're spending our time thinking
about rather than thinking about what um
former Prime Ministers are doing
everything Cube it about Boris Johnson
as well I won't know they always are
they can't they can never stop thinking
about Boris Johnson and you also asked
Mark Harper I think is is this a problem
is probably something a problem for the
conservative party and he said no
absolutely not Boris Johnson is a
problem for the conservative party the
Specter of Boris Johnson looms large and
I think there has been discussion we
heard a story we had a story this week
from our political correspondent Joe
Pike he had heard that Boris Johnson was
saying to Rishi sunak find me a safe
seat or I'll run against you uh you know
if you lose the next general election
um Boris Johnson's office uh denied that
we see this million pound donation it
looks quite clear that that is going to
be used for something and probably a
political campaign and it's not to
stretch to say that we know that Boris
Johnson uh has aspirations to be the
Prime Minister again because at the last
leadership election he stood against
Rishi well he spent weeks suggesting
that he was going to stand against which
you've seen that then he pulled out at
the last minute and said the timing
wasn't right which suggests that we will
see at some point I think another bid
for number 10 by Boris Johnson when do
you think the timing might be right you
know might he be waiting to see uh if
the polling doesn't change what happens
with the elections after Rishi suno
loses if he does I think for Boris
Johnson uh at any moment where the
current prime minister starts to look
weak at any moment when the current
conservative leader starts to look weak
he will start to have conversations and
think about what he wants to do next
Boris Johnson does not languish on the
back benches with a million pounds
particularly with a million with a
million pounds and just what is the
relationship like between what she's
doing and Boris Johnson because
obviously they were you know we were so
used to seeing them side by side right
as a chance from the Prime Minister and
then you know over party gay and more
recently as well it's felt like
I mean it's salad right what's going on
it's it's soured no question and the
interesting thing about Rishi soon I can
Boris Johnson was I think they always
got on uh whilst the Tories were doing
quite well and they were riding high in
the polls and before all the party gate
um stuff kicked off
they're clearly incredibly different
characters you know you only have to
look at them to see that they live very
different Lifestyles have very different
values and backgrounds but they got on
quite well because I think they felt
that they were both in the right role at
the right time and doing quite a good
job of it I think one of the interesting
things is that first of all I think it's
sad because of partygate because Rishi
sunak was dragged into a scandal that
really he you know we only have to
understand what Richard is like to to
see that he probably wouldn't have
created a scandal like that himself and
the other issue that I think was
Rishi sunak has very strict ideology on
how he thinks the public finances should
be run and Boris Johnson is a prime
minister was a person that every now and
again lurched suddenly into a huge
expensive costly policies and I think we
should see and I felt that that wasn't
the right direction for the country and
of course I don't need to describe the
subsequent leadership elections that
have happened and you know friendships
do tend to sell it during leadership
elections and I think um I don't think
they're going to be having dinner
together anytime soon no I think you're
probably uh right there it is right
isn't it about the different
personalities as well both in policy
terms and as men as well and just while
we've got you Liz and because it's uh
you know a treat to have you here in the
studio on Sunday what's your kind of
predictions for the year ahead you know
what's Russia's United got to do if he
is going to turn it around
well he set himself some targets and I
think they're quite good I think the you
know the interesting thing about the
strikes issue is that you compare the
way that Rishi sunak is approaching this
to Liz trust I think Liz trust in some
way she had an idea of herself as kind
of Margaret Thatcher taking on the union
she almost wanted uh the um the
hostility on both sides and this kind of
uh historic Showdown which is soon like
is a very different prime minister I
think he wants to get things sorted out
he's much more managerial he's he's much
more in the vein of a sort of David
Cameron sees himself as the sort of CEO
um more than uh you know a sort of
historic Prime ministerial figure so he
certainly needs to sort out these
industrial disputes cost of living he
set himself that Target bringing down
inflation and creating growth we we were
expecting the public finances to go in
that direction anyway
um so big challenges the polling with
labor he has to make himself more
popular and appealing how does he do
that
that's his challenge uh thanks so much
Liz a really interesting uh to talk well
that is it for some Sophia Ridge on
Sunday the take uh this week we will see
you next Sunday and also on Wednesday at
9pm for the take with safety Ridge
have a lovely rest of your weekend
[Music]